in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
the patient we just saw was suffering
from polyps what's the problem with
polyps polyps can eventually evolve into
two carcinomas malignant tumors and
those are the two message can kill
patients absolutely they can clear
patient's that's right since if you
perform a colonoscopy you see the polyps
and they can remove them yes that's the
goal you see the part you detect the
polyps and then your movement and
thereby you have prevent that
development into tumors so the
development how long does it take time
for the product to get into a Sonoma it
differs depending on tumor biology but I
can take decades ten to thirty years and
that it's very safe to find the Politzer
so if you do the colonoscopy do you find
every single polyp in the code not every
single part of it depends on the
expertise you have and on the technique
you use and but the sensitivities widely
over 90% and the polyps you find you
should aim at removing them when I think
about my patient is in my surgery and
I'd say you have to go to colonoscopy
for preventive medical reasons yes and
they always say oh they don't want to do
it is because it's a taboo area desired
so how how do you motivate your patients
now to do this I can't understand that
they feel ashamed somehow right but they
have a good reason to do it
firstly the most most people are afraid
of the procedure itself right well we
can tell them that you don't feel
anything during the procedure the
preparation is the worst thing once you
have actually done the preparation and
everything is just fine
and the vibration means the day before
yesterday yes about the tearing of the
bowel of the lab spot and then the
procedure itself you don't realize a
thing because you get a medication
Whitman said AT&T will not notice
anything and then of course the benefit
is enormous by removing a risk for
cancer you've done a good thing
to your son but some patients indeed are
afraid not only of the procedure but of
the result as well they don't want to
know if they have a problem and
therefore in Germany for example only
every five people have a fifth people do
it what about those other preventive
tests you could do we like looking into
the stool and see if there's blood in
the stores is this a good preventive
measure as well potentially yes but at
the present time no such test is good
enough not sensitive enough to replace
colonoscopy why's that because blood is
not our set by the tumors not at every
time point you're measuring the blood so
if you have an Eric negative blood test
that does not mean you have no tumor
okay and therefore that server that's a
big risk
it's called sensitivity and the
sensitivity of the test is just too low
I mean what about this new modern test
we don't look for blood itself that
you've got those in unit tests as long
as you test at the protein based test
which is more sensitive but not
sensitive enough in the future you will
look at the genes produced and shed by
tumor cells into the store
that's a nice technology but it's so
expensive at the present time but
perhaps in five to ten years we'll use
that chip technology we detect tumors at
the present time there's no way around
colonoscopy get back to the canal Skippy
isn't it a dangerous procedure if you
stick something into large barrels and
move around that could puncture them or
unless of course it has been done by an
expert as well-trained but if it's done
by an expert them the risk of causing
harm is far less than 1% in your clinic
how many polyps do you find here per
year - how many tumors you prevent by
finding him if you look close enough you
will find polyps in almost every patient
but not every polyp is a dangerous polyp
sometimes the pathologists will tell you
that sets of the nine thing there's
nothing harmful but sometimes you see
that this polyp is on its way to develop
into cancer and this one of course has
to be removed and then the follow-up
study should be performed say about
three years later but not ten years
later
okay and then your patients what you say
when should you start going to : Oscar
which which year in a healthy patient
with no positive family history meaning
that there's no other person with colon
cancer it's recommended as of age 55
okay and this is true for women and for
men that's right
men have a slightly increased risk of
men could do it at the age of 50 but
recommendation of fish recommendation is
55 where's the fun right ago thank you
so much you are
you